now usually i say
use these cards to ask questions
and
i think bob fuller's thinks that's a
little bit rankist
so the way he's going to approach it
tonight is that's why we kept the lights
up in the room
he doesn't have slides to show in a
sense you're the slides
so part way along through his talk
you'll go interactive
and uh not
intermediated through cards and be up
here deciding what's a good question
it's between you and him
if you look at bob fuller's book
you'll find a blurb on the back
present on the front
somewhere
that i wrote
saying that i think this is one of the
really important books ah here it is
inside robert fuller's ideas about
rankism changed my personal behavior
i think they will change the world in
time it is one of those click
realizations that you can't unclick
everything human looks different
afterward and you have to do something
about it
i think one of the reasons bob is having
so much success with getting this
dignitarian movement going
is one he knows
to just keep bearing down
and two he knows the history of
human rights of civil rights
and knows where this whole current
process fits in with that history
and that's what he's talking about
tonight bob fuller
i thought i'd talk about a half an hour
and then open it up to questions and
cover the rest of the material in that
way
mostly
i'll talk about america
these issues do apply globally
an awful lot of human rights are
universal rights
but
it requires too many qualifications and
too much knowledge i don't have to say
it all in a completely
trans-cultural way
so i'm going to use america as my ex the
example of this society in which
i think there's hope for a dignitarian
movement
the personal
is political
as we've learned from
the women's movement and every other
movement and for me
these ideas this analysis did grow out
of my personal history
and
since i don't know yours i'm going to
tell a little bit about mine
just to remind you of yours
i grew up in a town in new jersey
which
lacked all the usual
divides of race and religion and so on
uh black people weren't allowed in this
town
so there were no racial issues
it was a interesting town and it was
primarily divided into somebodies and
nobodies
because
it was in the shadow of bell telephone
laboratories the greatest scientific
establishment in the world at the time
it was just a few miles from there
half of my friends had parents who
worked there fathers
the other half
were the poor kids who
parents worked on dirt farms
but we were all white
and so i was not confused by race
uh
i remember
an incident from from
very early years
that seared into my brain and
came back to me later
and that i think is seminal to this
project
every morning we had to
show a clean white handkerchief and show
that our fingernails were clean
before the day began in second grade
and
one day arlene
was sent to the hall for the entire day
because her fingernails were dirty
and as we went to recess and passed her
slumped against the wall
near the drinking fountain
i was glad i wasn't in her shoes
but i didn't do anything about it
uh some of the kids teased her
at three o'clock she came in and took
the bus home came back into the
classroom
and for some reason witnessing this
event
i couldn't understand it at the time i
remember thinking how can she clean her
fingernails out there
but that was all
there was no moral judgment or anything
about it
even now i don't really blame the
teacher that's how it was in those days
the teacher's job really was to
separate the somebodies from the
nobodies
and
accommodate the nobodies to lives of
routine drudgery
and the others of us whose parents
worked at bell labs and a few of them
worked on wall street
were on a fast track to
college and everything else
yet on the playground i noticed that
the nobodies
really were no
less accomplished or intelligent or
interesting than the somebodies
and in fact i sometimes think i was born
with a nobody gene because
these were my better friends
the the somebodies were somehow
increasingly boring
and i found the nobodies interesting and
uh
put that all away
went on to
try to be like my father by going to
studying math and physics and going to
graduate school
and then the 60s happened
and
like like many of you and many at the
time in the academic world i identified
with
the groups that were protesting their
oppression
their second class citizenship
and
one thing led to another and
i got out of physics and and went to
oberlin as president
where i was in the thick of three or
four simultaneous
movements
of course there was the black movement
the women's movement and the student
movement
but there was also
a nascent gay movement
a movement
by
students with disabilities
there was no
need for a movement about
against anti-semitism because there was
none
like many schools it was an anglo-semite
college
it was
that wasn't an issue that one had been
handled
that was one of the seven or eight forms
of discrimination
that did get handled
before the turn of the century
it was obviously not handled until the
turn of the century
it was a calamity
but it wasn't as
to have one kind of potential prejudice
that was inoperative was instructive
and
prejudice against jews was one of those
perhaps it be it's because half the
scientists at bell labs were jewish
but i digress uh i want to
get to this
go through this list of isms
that we have been confronting in this
country
in the throughout the 20th century it
begins with anti-semitism
then there's racism
sexism
homophobia
classism ageism
and
that's it
you might think of another
couple and there's some varieties
in racism
dealing with african americans was not
enough there was also a
latino movement
and a native american movement and an
eskimo movement
and all of these groups were demanding
that
their
the people they identified with be
accepted into the college and treated
well and so on
it struck me at some point that all
these movements had something in common
that they were all manifestations of
somebody's
in power
discriminating against or oppressing or
treating badly nobodies
who lacked power who were relative to
the somebody's weak
so in this sense
whites were the somebodies blacks were
the nobodies
men were the somebodies women were the
nobodies
able-bodied people
people with disabilities
straits gays
over and over again
it seemed that the
distinguishing characteristic around
which the second-class citizenship was
defined was more an excuse
for ongoing predatory behavior
then it really was the cause of the
discrimination in question
so
at some point i was moved to think of a
word
that would describe all
the types of discrimination at once
whenever
somebodies were taking advantage of
nobody's
whenever
because of
rank
in a situation
that came with power
they could get away with treating people
who lacked that power badly
now
so i'll define rankism as abuse of the
power inherent in rank
now if we look back at those isms
there's no clear rank involved in them
but there is a more diffuse social rank
involved
that had been
built up and established
through decades and decades of practice
and it was very operative for for blacks
and for women and for gays
so much so that if you were a
fair-skinned black
you would try to pass as a white to
avoid the racism
if you were
a woman mathematician or writer in the
19th century you would adopt the
identity of a male so you could get
published
if you were gay you tried to pass a
straight
similarly
nobody's trying to pass as somebody's
what we do to avoid the rankism that is
endemic in the society
and it takes the form what it amounts to
always is that we fear someone with more
power
greater affiliations
uh actual
authority over us in many institutional
settings that such a person with higher
rank
will abuse their rank
and
we will be harmed in the process
now i'm not saying that rank is
inherently abusive it isn't in the
military it serves an obvious function
of organizing the troops so that they
can fight effectively
in a company
you need someone to make decisions in a
timely fashion in a university you need
to know who the professors are and who
the students are so this is not a
an analysis that invalidates rank
rank is very often but not always
necessary to effective organization
and and when it is
it's all the more important that it not
be abused abusively
because that undercuts its effectiveness
in the organization
so uh
rankism then
abuse of rank
occurs in society where the rank in
question is social rank established
constructed if you will
over decades and centuries even
of
legal and
of legal actions of
habits
of philosophical arguments
later found to be specious but
they seem to hold water at the time
and rankism also manifests not in
society as a whole but in every
organization within the society where
there are ranks
so for example
in in a company
the ceo of the highest rank
can abuse the rank by
extracting
personal favors from subordinates
when these take a sexual form we have a
special name for it now we didn't have
one 20 years ago but now we call it
sexual harassment that being a classic
example of rankism
when
a group of
high-ranking
executives abuse their rank to
essentially pad their own salaries or
write each other op stock options or
persuade the board to do things for them
that
are beyond anything they've earned then
that's a form of rankism it's the abuse
of rank to the disadvantage of employees
stockholders and customers
finally now in the last few years
the tide seems to be turning against
that kind of rank abuse
executives are actually going to prison
despite predictions by many many people
when enron first happened that no one
would ever go to prison over this
so there's a change in the wind
celebrities are still getting away with
murder
but
there may be a change there too
i feel it coming anyway
uh that's the kind of of rankism
when your celebrity status means that
you are
subjected to a different brand of
justice than someone who's weak and poor
so we have a lot of rankism built into
this our whole system of jurisprudence
because clearly
the rich can buy a much higher quality
defense than the poor
so they're examples of rankism that are
society-wide
they're examples that occur within
workplaces within schools within
hospitals
within
police
departments and this is a very broad
analysis saying
that in all its guises
rankism is unwarranted
dysfunctional
counterproductive it's more than just a
moral argument
it's an argument that says if you want
to make money
you'll make more if you have a less
rankist company
you'll make more if you have what i call
a dignitarian company because you'll
have the loyalty of your workers
you'll even have some customers who
appreciate the fact that you're treating
your workers with dignity and will come
to you rather than a company that they
know abuses their customers
in health care
we're witnessing a revolution
in
the status of doctors vis-a-vis patients
most of us are old enough to have gotten
doctors orders
when we were kids and it was unthinkable
to violate them
doctors now are going through a process
not of equalizing their rank with
patients most of them still know way
more than we do
but they are
now expected
actually to listen to the research we've
done on the internet before we come to
see them
they're expected to realize that we have
support groups and our real partners in
our own health care
and
the best of them
want that
they think it's
produces a higher quality care
if the patients
are partners in their own treatment
doctors are famously
abused in the course of their education
and when they finally make it they often
turn around and visit that abuse on
people of lower status like nurses
but it's a general principle about
rankism that when it's done to you you
want to do it to somebody else
so nurses turns out there are four ranks
of nurses
and they're quite abusive to each other
right on down to the candy stripers the
lowest
rank in nursing really volunteers
different modalities of medicine treat
each other with disdain
and
denigrate different
kinds of practitioners the m deities
being at the top of the food chain
in that regard
i recently
worked with
with several dozen
physicians i have to call them because
there were mds there were naturopaths
homeopaths every kind of path all sorts
of different holistic and alternative
medicine people and they had realized
that they were
at such war with each other
that they weren't really doing the best
they could
in terms of health care for the
society so they wanted a
whole day devoted to the rankism that
exists within the mode
between the modalities and health care
and the mds were leading this they were
quite enlightened md or they wouldn't
have done so
which brings up another point about
movement politics
it always takes someone in the oppressor
class to get it going
because the oppressed are at such
tremendous risk if they speak out
when black spoke out they were silenced
by lynching
when women spoke out
they were humiliated
gays were beaten up it takes some help
in the initial stages of a movement from
what i call generically the white
liberal
the person who is
sympathetic to the nobodies
in that particular movement and speaks
out until they
find their voice
uh i'm finding so far with regard to the
dignitarian movement that most
of the people willing to speak out about
it
are people who do have some power
but the interesting thing about rankism
is
that
we are all victims and perpetrators of
this particular ism it differs from the
other isms in that regard so basically
i could look around this room and
instantly
and so could any of you tell who has
possibly been a victim of racism in this
room
and who of sexism
just guess who would have been a victim
of homophobia would require a little
interrogation
can't spot it instantly
we can pick out people who have been
ridiculed for
disabilities but we can't
it
rankism is different because you can be
sure that everyone has been a victim of
it and you can be almost equally sure
that everyone has perpetrated it
because it is something that
rankism begets rankism
so you can't end rankism with more
rankism
because the
the feud continues the dynamic just
continues endlessly
in contrast to sexism which you can end
with rankism
and that's what the women did at the
initial stages they humiliated men who
indulged in sexism and it effectively
suppressed it
but it didn't disappear it
it lurked waiting for a chance to make a
comeback
because you can't get rid of sexism as a
kind of rankism and you can't ultimately
get rid of any kind of rankism with more
rankism you have to find a way to
preserve the dignity of your
tormentor
while offering correction and that is
very difficult
but not impossible
uh
let's see where to wrap up i want to
wrap up my part i i want to explain just
a bit about
dignitarian movement
uh it's named it to contrast it with
egalitarian movements of the past
which have been
seriously discredited by the fact that
their embodiments were communism
basically
and these were in fact not egalitarian
at all they were profoundly rankest
in that the all the political control
was retained at the top
they were at the antithesis of
democracies and democracies represent a
big step towards non-rankest government
they're not all the way to dignitarian
government but it's a big step because
it solves the problem of abusive
governors by letting them know they will
be accountable to the people and we can
fire them periodically
and that is a tremendous improvement
over an absolute monarch
in terms of
reducing rankism potential for rankism
but it's uh
doesn't
necessarily deliver dignity to all the
citizens in a democracy as we know
to
make that next step
democracy's next step
to a dignitarian society
means we have to create institutions
and laws
which actually protect the dignity of
everyone in the society
it's a tall order
but it seems to me it's it can be
realized if we're patient
if we
start at home
start in our own families and our
personal relationships
stewart mentioned it affected his
you begin to catch yourself
in rankist acts
acts of
superciliousness of domineering
of
denigration of ridicule
of sneering
you catch yourself
acting in a way
that
is a is a damaging assertion of presumed
rank
why do we do this
i think we do it because
we are predators
we are great predators
best the world has ever seen and none of
us would be here if our ancestors hadn't
been even better at it than other
people's ancestors people who were dead
who were eaten
i'm going back now ten thousand years
twenty thousand years when it was really
rough out there
but we have a predatory history and we
wouldn't have gotten this far without it
and now we're at a stage
where opportunities for cooperation
abound if we can
retire our predaciousness
if we can get past it and we have
learned amazingly to do that and
countries that have done it they're
called democracies have turned out to be
more powerful than countries that still
celebrate predation
because they enlist more loyalty more
partnership more cooperation more
initiative more creativity
i think the same will hold true at the
scale of
companies hospitals
and most of all schools
schools are places where people go in
expecting to be humiliated
half the kids in school hate it
this is a tremendous indictment of what
is the most important function in a
society is that half your customers hate
it
i still do
you can feel it
and i tried to do something about it and
it's impossible
you can only get a chance twice a
century to change education and it has
to ride piggyback on some other
movements
because the
institutions of education are so
profoundly rankist
that it's like being a black person in
the south and complaining about
something you just get lynched
figuratively
you don't get tenure
the the situation in in our schools
today is
and they'll be the last to catch on
because they're so
self-satisfied about their marvelous
record and civil rights
and overcoming racism and sexism and so
on but rankism is their achilles heel
and where it is that academics are going
to have to face the music eventually
and realize that from k through graduate
school most students
are not doing half as well as they could
if we could pull the systemic
humiliation and
and
and ridicule out of the system the
elitism
this has nothing to do with excellence
you can have excellence you can
celebrate it
without the ridicule
without the disdain without the snobbery
without the obfuscation that
characterizes so much of higher
education
uh
so a dignitarian movement simply insists
that regardless of rank
everyone every human being has equal
dignity
it has some political implications and
interestingly they're neither left nor
right
they're about dignity
and conservatives care as much about
dignity as liberals do
at least their own
liberals identify more with nobodies
first conservatives identify more with
somebody's so liberals do tend to look
after other people's
dignity a little more than conservatives
but conservatives care very much about
their own i recently spoke in boulder
where coming from berkeley people liked
me before i opened my mouth they're very
progressive there
and i spoke in idaho where before i
opened my mouth people were profoundly
skeptical
they're very conservative there
and at the end i felt
equally
equal interest from both groups
what would a dignitarian politics look
like
well
a person can't have dignity that can't
make a living wage
uh
enough
to take care of himself and his
dependents
a family living wage since you'll
sometimes have two people working
and it shouldn't require two or three
jobs to make that
make enough money to support your family
so right there we have what most people
would think is a progressive implication
of dignitarianism
but it really is just about simple
dignity and not exploiting
a third of the country which we are
moving ever closer to locking into a
permanent underclass
that isn't the america i was brought up
in and it's not the america most
americans want and it contradicts the
american dream
so
i think a political case can be made for
doing something about
locking one third of the population into
permanent
roles in the underclass
another thing a dignitarian politics
would do would be to provide everyone
with emergency
and preventative health care
this is elementary
and also
access to quality higher education
those are typically
kind of liberal programs but they can be
inferred from an assumption of dignity
another thing though that
a dignitarian society would embody would
be that it would
protect dignity but not jobs
this goes against some of the support on
the left which are always worried about
job security
what you want to protect is someone's
not their right to a job let alone a
lifetime right to that job as in
academia 40 50 60 years sometimes
on the basis of one decision made in the
mid-20s
it's a catastrophe
it also prices education out of reach of
the middle class because you end up
paying these senior professors who most
of whom are deadwood
three times as much as a beginning
professor and who pays the bill to
students who can't afford it
so
tenure is the right to a job not the
right to dignity everyone has the right
to dignity but you can get that by
changing jobs and by facilitating the
change of jobs
and by having obviously i'm not saying
college administrators should fire these
people it has to be done in a dignified
way as a result of peer review and so on
but all those things are in place and
can be made to work
and throughout the whole society we
could have dignity dignity security
which would mean
you don't just down someone downsize
someone onto the street you
have job retraining programs available
when
employment levels have to shift due to
economic factors
there are other aspects of a dignitarian
society but the main thing about it is
it would have to be worked out by the
people themselves you can't impose
anything and call it dignitarian i'm
just guessing as to what the process
would
uh
would produce
at oberlin we ran
for a year
a committee on the status of women
that whose job was to go around and talk
to anybody who would listen about
ways in which women felt that college
was
uncongenial
was insulting their dignity and
this committee collected 23
recommendations and took them to the
people who had the power to change it
so some came to the president some came
to deans some went to the board
some of these changes could be made
overnight some of them take a year some
take 10 years some had to go to the
whole faculty for a vote
but it's a process through which any
group
can
create a more dignitarian environment
for itself
and it worked
that same process would have to be
undertaken in any society that wants to
make itself over transform itself from a
rankist organization
into a dignitarian one now it's not
overtly rankist a lot of racism wasn't
overt
a lot of sexism wasn't overt it's just
a
de facto rankist
and once these conversations begin once
rank the taboo on rank is broken and
it's out of the closet
it
yields an amazing conversation about
ways in which people feel disloyal to
the organization in question because
their dignity is constantly under
assault in it
i've seen this happen in universities
and hospitals
and
it's always takes some uh
running interference by a seeing very
senior person who makes it okay and
guarantees safety
for these kind of conversations to begin
it takes a chancellor
like like the one at university of
massachusetts who initiated this
conversation in the whole university
or a administrator of a hospital like
kaiser richmond which is looking at
these kind of
effects within that hospital
and it will take that nationally and my
hope is that
a political leader will emerge who's
willing to
move past the old isms
and talk about this
still largely invisible
kind of abuse and
discrimination that i'm calling ranchism
and propose as an alternative that we
build a dignitarian society
people are willing to stand up for their
dignity long before they're willing to
demand justice
but once they're on their feet
they'll work their way towards justice i
see dignity as a stepping stone
a halfway house
between
the justice that's missing and the
justice that we could and
and should create in this country if
it's actually supposed to be liberty and
justice for all
let me stop at this point and see if
there are any questions or comments
yeah um
you don't
you're not assuming are you that
it is going to cost you more money
to be less rankist
yeah they do
but it doesn't necess isn't necessarily
the case because you can
you can increase your loyalty and
productivity and creativity and
companies like intel are famous for
abolishing rankism
on the technical side of the company
where young people are brought in told
from the get-go that that they are free
to attack
anyone's idea no matter how senior
and
they try to embody this with a structure
of cubicles and
leveling
architectural leveling
that makes it easier for the brash 20
year old just out of computer science
school to
challenge andy grove so
in in that limited way
uh
rankism
has been effectively abolished in in
certain technical companies but not
completely so because andy gross still
makes 100 million a year
and and the brash young kid makes you
know tens of thousands
and so his salary i'm exaggerating i
don't even know and i think he's retired
but
you know how those things go i mean the
people when they finally get ranked the
first thing they do is self-aggrandize
with it
and that means
taking the board on a retreat to a
lovely location and whining and dining
them and then have a meeting of the
compensation committee in which it votes
that you should get some gigantic salary
increase
and this happens in academia and in
companies and so on and we're just
beginning to challenge it now because
it's uh
it's it's
it's just unwarranted
it's not so in japan and in europe where
the
the factor separating the lowest paid
from the highest paid
is
10 or 20
or maybe 30 but in america it's 500.
i
don't know what to say to give you
specific other examples
one that comes to mind is whole foods
whole food is famously a good place to
work
everyone i i always ask the checkout
people and
i've read about it and uh it has a ceo
who pays himself i think 17 times what
the janitors are paid
and who has a whole atmosphere of equal
dignity functioning in the company and
it's doing well
walmart is doing well too and it does
not have a dignitarian culture but it is
every
month that passes you feel walmart
getting in hotter water
cost what's the other one
costco
yeah yeah costco is is clearly trying to
be much more dignitarian
i predict that just as democracies beat
out
tyrannies
because of the loyalty and the
creativity that they
contain and promote
so too dignitarian organizations are
going to beat out rankist ones
if not
then morality can't be grounded in
causality
that
then morality has to be an add-on
and that is a much weaker defense of
morality than if you can argue it's
actually more effective productive
efficient
and cost saving
one at a
time one at a time in one institution at
a time this is why it's a patient
revolution
i don't think it's going to take the
form of million man marches
i think it's going to take the form of
millions of institutions
transformed
one at a time
as
some courageous employee
brings up the discussion and forces the
boss to to deal with this new kind of
abuse
now it may sometimes be ugly and other
times it will be dignified and when it's
the latter it'll be more effective
because you can't cure racist rankism
with rankism so if the
victim of rankism is rankest in
attempting to overcome it it won't work
you have to find a way now you usually
can
and
i've become alert to this and and look
for ways that i can
behave
that will protect the dignity of the
person who is the rankest
while at the same time trying to show
them
another way
examples like the head of whole foods
and costco
who gets stories
characterizing them as the anti-walmart
are also teaching this
but i really don't think it's going to
be a mass movement i think it's except
finally at the political level
it it could take the form of a candidate
for off high office
10 12 years from now
saying
we've come as far as we can go on all
the separatisms
we're running into diminishing returns
on
improving situations for
african-americans for women for gays and
disabled and so on
in order to get at the remnants of all
those historic types of civil rights
violations
we're going to have to take generalize
the problem and take on this larger
problem of abuse of power period
and that's going to be this candidate's
campaign and he's going to have to give
examples of enron and worldcom type
bosses of priests who abuse their rank
for
personal advantages
the sexual abuse scandal is a perfect
example of rankism the abu ghraib
scandal is another example of rankism
yeah
right
that's where the singularity comes in
uh
it's a terrible legacy to overcome
except it's amazing how rapidly we do i
mean if i go back in my own family four
generations i have out and out racists
who would happily have participated in a
lynch mob
i know this is true
if i go back to my grandparents they
used the n word openly but they would
not have participated in a lynch mob my
parents did not use the n-word and as a
result me and my brothers did not have
to unlearn it
when the revolution came
my own kids date interracially
that's four or five generations the
thing moves it's amazing how fast that
when a category of behavior becomes
disallowed and is no longer condoned it
diminishes at an exponential rate in the
society
so three or four generations is enough
to really put the kibosh on some of
these behaviors and and the
corresponding ism goes into the dog
house
if you're caught being a racist now your
career is over
or a sexist
it's still you can get by with a little
homophobia but within 10 years that's
going to end your career too
within 20 years i'm hoping that if
you're found to be a rankist your career
will be stymied
we'll see
who else yeah
well
it's a crucial i have a whole chapter on
that subject in
the sequel to somebody's and nobody's
which is called dignity
and it's a crucial point religions
are not necessarily
imperious but they're often
fundamentalists what i'm saying is
they're
the word fundamentalism is tricky some
fundamentalists simply cling to their
own views and are not forcing them on
anybody and not
demeaning people with other views they
just think that those particular views
are true for them and they're going to
humbly follow them
but many more religions proselytize
and look down upon people who aren't
co-religionists
in fact it's even spreading to what has
historically been the most tolerant
inclusive religion of all time hinduism
the the three jerusalem-based religions
or mideast-based religions are all
proselytizers but the asian ones less so
now hinduism is picking up the
the virus
it's it's
what i call spiritual rancism
and and it's got to be lumped in with
the other forms of rankism as something
that is uh
we need to to grow beyond
and i think there are many leaders of
all these religions who feel that
strongly and their many ecumenical
movements
and even though fundamentalism in its
imperial form is much in the news today
and it looks like it's growing
everywhere and we're all a little
frightened of it i think it's doomed
but but nobody's going to church in
europe
what does that mean
a hundred years ago those churches were
packed
50 years ago they were full
now there's nobody in churches in europe
what does that mean
it means that with enough education
religion in its more primitive form
doesn't wash
it doesn't mean that religion is doomed
because there are aspects of religion
which can sail right on and which will
still have tremendous value
but when religion gets into the business
of science it comes out a very poor
second
and it loses out to
in educated uh societies
so i think it looks like it's on the
upswing now but that's mainly because it
is allied with certain political causes
which do have a certain validity
and
where there are many aggrieved people
many many people feeling that their
lives are wasted and useless
and
these people use religion as a banner
just like
the vietnamese used communism as a
banner but it really wasn't the
communism that was motivating them it
was the nationalism
uh
stuart
is
we've got a huge chunk of it when we've
got that because that's the abuse of
power
and in a ways that are deleterious to
people who have less of it
so it's a big agenda
i i think there is a uh
exponential acceleration in rights i
date the
great breakthrough for western folks
as occurring 800 years ago at runnymede
where the power went from one guy
king john to 10
the barons
they figured out how to gang up on king
john and threaten him with collective at
military action if he didn't sign the
magna carta
so they overcame the absolutist rankism
of the king
they curtailed or circumscribed his
sovereignty
and they set in motion
democracy
to get from one to ten took four billion
years
or let's say a hundred thousand for the
species
homo sapiens
yeah but it wasn't a real one i mean
neither was neither was
neither was running made a democracy it
was just the principle from one to ten
and there was an earlier one the greek
one and there were others even earlier
in native american society i'm always
reminded of when i give this spiel but
that's why i prefaced it by saying in
our immediate western tradition
because 400 years after running made
they had moved from 10 barons to 400
aristocrats had to say
they had a parliament
and 400 years after that they moved to
universal suffrage
for people over 18.
that's where we are now
it was a long hard shlog
i mean the the women who started the
campaign for
women's suffrage
didn't even live
to see
women get it
i'm thinking of susan b anthony on our
dollar and elizabeth katie stanton who
wrote the book about it that motivated
susan
they both died before 1920 when women
finally got the vote
and
then there was another 50 years before
the vote was lowered from 21 to 18
and in that time blacks were actually
given the vote instead of just in
principle given the vote
and
i see it as an exponentially
accelerating thing next up is going to
be people under 18
not that they should actually cast the
vote when they're three days old
i understand that or even five years old
although the berkeley high school kids
are lobbying for the actual vote now but
more important than that is representing
the political interests of these human
beings they are unrepresented and that's
why they're screwed
every group that doesn't have voting
representation their interests are
ignored by the politicians we have to
find a way
to give
electoral weight to the interests
of
young people
else the society is going to ossify and
calcify
as people live longer and longer and
vote more and more their own special
interests
so
john vasconcellis our senator from the
bay area
got that idea from somebodies and
nobody's and introduced a bill
in
sacramento to give young people the vote
but it was killed in committee
uh
did i just want come to finish my
stewart's point uh
stewart i think
it's not going to take a thousand more
years i i think if you look at it from
runnymede to the parliament to universal
suffrage and the bumps in the road that
got us there
i can see uh
and all that does is create a kind of
democracy which is only so so
when it comes to delivering dignity
so delivering dignity ups the ante i
think of it as democracy's next
evolutionary step
i think it's going to happen within 50
years because countries that don't do it
are going to be beat out by countries
that do
so it's the great question is is america
going to does we have one
last gasp in us
are we gonna we've led the way on a lot
of these movements
it's
almost unthinkable to think fondly of
america these days
in california but actually
most of the world still thinks we're
great
except for our foreign policy in the
mideast
most of the world still wants to move
here
and
and i think uh we might just possibly be
the place to pull off a dignitarian
society first
if not the countries that do will take
the leadership
yeah um
yeah
yeah oh there's going to be
everything we saw to defeat the black
movement is going to happen
10 times over to defeat the dignitarian
movement every possible chicanery and
conning
and finally
people are going to see through it
and and it isn't going to work anymore
they'll come a magical moment as there
have been in every one of these
movements where
someone simply voices the obvious in a
non-defensive
dignity protecting way and everybody
says yeah
like when when that fellow in the
mccarthy hearing said have you no
uh decency senator mccarthy
and he said that in front of the whole
nation watching on television and
mccarthy died three weeks later
i mean the movement collapsed he
literally died
is the very oppositional nature of those
systems
no the opposition isn't you can have a
left and a right to steer a group
first favoring more power to authority
and then attacking to
circumscribe that authority a little
more usually the left is the party that
circumscribes power and the right is the
party that
uh invests authority in things and both
tendencies are crucial to the survival
of a nation
so it's silly if we talk as in the right
way we're all a bunch of jerks they're
actually
defending the locating of authority so
that the society can function
and the left is equally crucial if one
party if the right gets
goes to its ultimate it becomes
fascist
if the left goes to its ultimate extreme
it becomes a giant quaker meeting
and immediately conquered an avalanche
by some country some other country
the abolition of partisanship but it
does not advocate the abolition of
extremist fundamentalist partisanship
ideological
kind of commitments that become blind
those are not useful
so what about the reform of the system
the reform of the system is vital we
right now have a very ranked electoral
system whereby a money is buying votes
and so that's what
the bill was supposed to deal with
and finals bill was supposed to deal
with but it doesn't go far enough we
have to get the money out of politics
because that's an inherently distorting
and rank this feature of the political
process
and return it to a real democracy you
know and we've got to find a way to get
the 50 million people who aren't 18 yet
get their interests represented
that's a big change germany has an
interesting solution to this by the way
they're gonna they're proposing this is
just a mechanism not i'm not favoring
this mechanism mechanism germany's
proposing is that a mother of one gets
two votes mother of three gets four
votes
now it does accomplish it does give some
helping weight to the interest of the
children
yeah you can you can give the father
some you know
it's a detail
yeah
it was kind of
there's this idea that the evolutions
have driven the direction of predation
but isn't human homo sapiens evolution
very heavily
in the advances of cooperation like
development of language
social evolution uh building
relationships
definitely so it's like one of the main
thrusts of human evolution is the area
of cooperation
yeah we still just have a lot of
predatory behavior left over
and and it turns out cooperation is more
powerful than predation
we've got to wrap this up in the next
minute or so let me
why don't you ask god
that
these people are driving around in their
hummers for themselves while they're
sending their sons and daughters off to
die
okay
it's okay to try to be the next michael
jordan he's a great basketball player
this analysis celebrates excellence
and if he's ranked number one so be it
until someone else is a better
basketball player
that doesn't affect anybody's dignity
when i lose a race on the track i don't
feel i've lost my dignity i just lost
the race
now
as for the strutting that comes with it
that is rankings that is demeaning to
other people
the fact that michael
that these superheroes get all the girls
they get all the money all these things
have randomized elements to them
but the fact that he's great at
basketball doesn't
and as for the hummer
it's kind of a statement that i am you
know a somebody and it's a form of
strutting
and it's uh
i would expect to see
it's it's
it's disappearance in time
just as overt racists
and good old boy sexists
are not in favor anymore
but they sure were when i was young
well i'm glad to stay around and ask and
answer any more questions or talk if uh
you